(attendees applauding)
- [Gary] Good job.
- [Man] Thanks.
(attendees applauding)
♪ Gotta Gucci from outside ♪
- Yo!
(attendees cheering)
Toronto, thank you for having me.
Thank you for the warm welcome.
There's a lot of things we can cover.
We decided to do a ton of Q and A
so I've only got a short
period of time here
to kinda spit it.
And so what I'm gonna really
focus on in this kind of moment
is gonna piggyback off
the last presentation
which is a lot of this is about
mindset and overall strategy
of how you're navigating your
life and your business life
and your personal life.
This is just about do you see
what's happening or don't you,
do you understand how this
plays out in the macro
or are you too consumed with the things
that are in front of
you in the short term.
It's really hard to project blockchain's
impact on our society
if you're just caught up
in the headlines of Bitcoin, right?
And so for me, as I navigate my my life
and think about why
things have worked for me
is I go under one very basic assumption
which is as long as I stay alive,
it's always better to think
long-term than short-term.
And the other thing that runs
in parallel to that strategy
is my inability to allow
one of your opinions
to matter more to me than
my own opinion about myself.
Not because I think I'm great or special,
it's just that I think
you suck at shit too.
So for me, the themes of
what's been happening,
why entrepreneurship has
been put on a pedestal
and is popular, what's
happening with the internet
at its maturity, the fact
that there's so many phones
being held up right now.
All these different
things that are happening,
what does it really mean?
What it means is there's
a group of people,
a small percentage of people
that navigate their life decisions
from a place of confidence
and emotional stability.
And think in terms of legacy and impact
and things in the long game.
And there's a group of people
that think about insecurities,
needing to buy things to
cover up their insecurities
so they need cash in the short term
because a pair of Supremes or
a BMW is gonna close the gap
of their insecurity and
then there's the in-between.
And so for me, I'm very
focused on the fact
that the stuff that I believe
in seemed like a fairytale
or bullshit just 30 years ago
because the internet didn't exist.
For all the youngsters
that I see in the audience,
they don't understand
the world pre-internet.
They don't understand
a world pre-smartphone.
I'm fucking old.
I remember I was 18 before
I ever spent 24 hours
on a computer in my lifetime.
I know what the world looked like.
It wasn't practical to have debt
and work you're nine to
seven and then come home
and make something of yourself.
I struggle to complain about anything
in a world that is this special.
You can decide to look at something narrow
and decide stuff sucks
or you a shortcoming
or you can understand the macro
and let's call it very simply
what it is because it's truth.
This is the greatest moment to be alive
in the history of the human race.
(attendees applauding)
'Cause it is.
And so for me, I take it super macro.
If I wake up this morning
and none of the seven or eight
people that I love the most
died overnight, I'm
optimistic, I feel in control.
There's always shit.
How many people here are an entrepreneur
or aspire to be one?
(attendees applauding)
Great.
For all the youngsters in here,
let me give you the first
thing that I believe
is true about entrepreneurship.
It's lonely as fuck.
Right?
Because when you don't
succeed on a team or in school
or at a job, here's what you do, team.
It was my player teammate's fault.
School, fuck the teachers, right?
Work, my boss is a fucking idiot.
When you fail in
entrepreneurship, all eyes on you.
Your fault.
You, and guess what, everybody's watching.
So we're living right now
through a very glamorous
moment of entrepreneurship.
Where it's cool, where a
lot of people wanna put it
in their Instagram photo and profile
because it tells the world who they are.
To me, it's an interesting
time for entrepreneurship.
Anything that swings too
far one way or the other
becomes vulnerable.
When the global economy and
definitely, the US economy,
different than the Canadian one,
when the US economy collapses
because we are loaning
way too much money to kids
that are carrying enormous college debt
and aren't making enough
to pay their debt back,
let alone the house or car
or thing they're buying
with their loan when
the US economy crashes
because of college debt and
the economy really suffers.
Two things will fall in popular opinion.
Number one, the institution of colleges
in the United States.
Number two, the fantasy
of entrepreneurship.
98% of the hands that
just went up will fail
and work in a job in six years.
Yet, everybody just thought
I'm one of the 2% that isn't
which is awesome and do it
and I can't wait for you two kill it.
But I will say that while we are talking
about all these things
right now, my propaganda,
my push, my want for people
to debate during this talk
is not that I'm gonna rah rah you up
and you're gonna go
fucking crush your business
but I am gonna hope to
put pressure on everybody
in this room to get really
self-aware really fast.
I think the reason I have a happy life
and things have gone well
and more importantly,
forget about me being
a focus group of one,
everybody that I know that has happiness
traces back to some incredible,
incredible commitment to self-awareness.
An incredible thing happens in your life
when you stop bullshitting yourself.
Look, I wish I was a lot of things too.
I wish I was the quarterback
of the New York Jets,
not gonna happen.
I wish I was a supermodel,
I wish a lot of things too.
But when you romanticize and wish
instead of actually being
practical and understand,
you create a vulnerability.
And let me remind some,
this group of people about something
that's very important to me.
Right, show hands.
Who's under 30 years old?
Raise your hands.
Fuck.
(attendees laughing)
Actually, I want everybody to see what I,
thank you for the lights.
If you were under 30,
I want you to stand up.
That's what's up.
(attendees applauding)
So couple things, keep staying
up because I want this.
A couple things.
Number one, one of my
least favorite things
in society right now is the
demonization of the youth
and saying like millennials
are lazy and entitled.
That's straight fucking bullshit.
(attendees applauding)
It is.
Because for all us sitting,
90% of our friends were fucking lazy too.
However, on the flip side,
here's my biggest concern
for everybody who's standing.
Everybody who's standing
has one fatal flaw
in the game of entrepreneurship,
and it's not your fault by the way.
Your fatal flaw is you
haven't been punched
in the fucking mouth yet.
For everybody that's sitting,
we've lived through the
meltdown of the economy in 2008
and 2001 and 1996 and on and on and on.
Everybody here who's rolling right now
has rolled under ridiculous easy game.
Ridiculous easiness of global economy.
Unlimited fucking money in the system.
Doesn't take a hero to raise capital
and lose money every month.
And so, the only thing I asked
for everybody who's sitting,
and your more than welcome
to sit down, thank you.
For everybody who is standing,
the one thing I want you
to understand is that truth
in the same way that
it's straight horseshit
that people say millennials
are entitled and are lazy,
it's the same that you have to understand
that you have not been
punched in the mouth.
You have not woken up in the
morning and 30% of the money
in the economy has been taken out
and then another week later, 50%
and all those brand deals,
because you got a lot of
Instagram followers go away.
And so I implore everybody in this room
regardless of where you
are to get real practical.
The two businesses I built,
my dad's liquor store for him
and VaynerMedia for me and my brother,
I built when I started them
in really tough economies.
Adversity was my strength.
It wasn't easy.
There was no raising capital.
I've run two companies my entire life.
for all my GaryVee time,
from the day I left school at 22 years old
to the way I'm standing right now,
in those 20 years, there
has not been a single day
in my life that I have
not operated a business
and there's not been a single time
in that entire 20 year period
where I didn't make more money
than I lost so I could pay my bills.
It's called practicality.
It's called building an actual business.
And so it's cool that you have
a T-shirt with a logo on it
and you're a lifestyle fashion brand
until the economy crashes
and you have to work at fucking Rogers.
(attendees laughing)
(attendees applauding)
Now look, look.
Don't get it twisted.
I'm not on a hike or standing
up here saying I'm successful
and you're not yet or
anything cool like that.
I'm desperate for you to
win and for you to win,
you have to have business principles.
You have to be able to
sustain your business
and you have to understand
that when there's an abundance
that is not always gonna
be the way it's going to be
and so are you with your
profits if you're crushing it,
are you putting that back into
your business or saving that
or you buying dumb shit
to look good on Instagram?
These are things you have to think about.
This is real life and real
life will rear its head
very soon, sooner than later.
I have no idea if I did.
I would play the markets that way.
Nobody really understands
when, how or for what reason
but it's just the way it's always been.
And guess what, I don't feel comfortable
when the global economy is
getting close to a decade
of prosperity because it usually
isn't able to hold on that long.
Now there's been enormous
amounts of manipulation
of government supporting it
but fundamentals are fundamentals.
And so I stand here today
trying to get people
into the right mindset
of the yin and yang of what's happening,
which is both things are true.
A, it's unbelievable that
things have been so good
for so long and it's a good time
to start strategizing what if.
What if I can't raise any
money for my business,
does my business make money?
What if the biggest companies
in the world and startups
and other businesses go out of business
and they don't have money to give me?
What if?
At the same token, what
makes this time tricky
is that the internet is
starting to hit such a scale
and such an opportunity
that there is a land grab
and more opportunity than ever
for the individual businesses
and anything else.
It's incredible to me that you
can start a brand from zero,
have a smart Instagram
and Facebook strategy,
sell it on Shopify Plus and Amazon
and build a real business
in a year or two.
That is remarkable, that is incredible
and that is what makes this era special.
Let me tell you this and
I referenced it earlier.
My friends, humans will
look back at this era,
they will look back at this
year like you are living
in one of those interesting times
that will be reviewed
over and over and over
because you live during the era
of the internet being established,
a blockchain being established.
This is big fucking shit.
This is big big fucking shit.
This is printing press, this is big.
This is big, big, big, big, big
and so now, what you have to do
is be on the offense practically.
There's people in the defense,
there's people fear
mongering technology, right?
Right, watch the subtleties.
We're shitting on technology.
We're blaming Facebook
because we don't like
to blame ourself, right?
Facebook didn't vote for you, asshole.
And so and so and so,
we live in an incredible time
where the opportunity for the
entrepreneur, the educator,
the stay-at-home mom, the
litigator, this is for everybody.
My biggest plea here
today is for everybody
who is sitting down.
If you're 47 years old and
you think you're finished,
you need to rethink everything.
I am so frustrated by
watching all the teenagers
and 20 year olds take full
advantage of this opportunity
because they don't know any better.
And for the 40 and 50 and 60 year olds,
closing their mind without realizing
that they're gonna live
for the next 40 years
and this fucking land grab is for you too
and good news, old fuckers,
you have experience.
(attendees applauding and cheering)
I'm fucking 42.
I'm not fucking young, I'm not a baby.
I just understand how
good the opportunity is
and I struggle with my 46 and
59 and 67 year old friends
who think because that's how we grew up
that they're getting
to the end of the years
without recognizing how much
healthier we are as a race
in our 70s, 80s and 90s.
You compound how fast
medicine is advancing,
there's a farm,
I mean if you're if you're
40 to 60 in this room,
your numbers are gonna look
like 100, 110, a hundred like,
what do people think is happening here
and if you're 63 in this room
and you're living another 50 years,
you're only at half time
but when we grew up,
you were towards the end
and I am imploring everybody in this room
from the youngest fuckers in this room
to the oldest of fuckers the in this room,
I'm imploring you, I'm
imploring you to understand
how incredible this is
which is the following.
Ronald fucking Reagan ran the
free world with a computer
not as powerful as this
only five minutes ago.
Shit's happening and you need
to take advantage of your thing.
And the fact that most of
you are not taking advantage
of this opportunity
because of the insecurities
that your fucked up parents or
your neighborhood gave to you
breaks my fucking heart.
And I am completely obsessed
with putting out content
that scale to get people to understand
that not posting on things on social media
because Johnny Pants 47
said you're ugly or stupid.
Watching my 60 year old
friends not do things
because they feel weird of the
judgment of their grandkids
making fun of them that
they don't understand
how to use Snapchat, remind
your 13 year old granddaughter
that she doesn't know
jack shit about life.
(attendees laughing)
And so I really, really need people
to understand what's
actually happening here.
(attendees applauding and cheering)
Good job, buddy.
- [Woman] What's your name?
- [Ashton] My name is Ashton Arsha.
(attendee speaking off mike)
(attendees applauding)
It takes hours.
I strategize.
(attendee speaking off mike)
- [Attendee] Sit down!
- I got you, good hustle.
(attendees laughing)
Couple things.
If you sit in this room and you
have any business ambitions,
any business ambitions, any
ambitions to raise money
for the disease that
took your parent's life,
if you have any ambitions to
raise money for your school
to build a new gym or any
other thing in the world,
please understand the following.
If you do not understand
how to make written words,
pictures and videos on
Facebook and Instagram
and do not do that multiple
times a day every day,
you are missing the fucking boat.
If you sit in this room
today and do not know
how to post pictures
written, words and videos
and then how to run ads as little as $50
up to as much as you can afford to spend
on Facebook and Instagram,
you are missing your fucking moment.
This has only happened on the internet
one other chapter at this scale
to make impact this quickly.
It was called the Google era.
Google was grossly underpriced ads.
People didn't understand in 2000 to 2004
but a couple people did.
Amazon understood which is why
it was the biggest advertiser
on Google during those years.
When we have a moment, when
there is underpriced attention,
you have to go all-in.
How many people here play poker?
Great.
All right.
Loves his fucking poker.
I don't because I recognize
people have better math skills
than me and I don't wanna lose my money,
but I know enough to know that
when you have the best hand,
you go all-in.
Facebook and Instagram
ads right this minute
are the best hand.
If you are not reinvesting
in your business
or your ambitions by putting ads
into Facebook and Instagram,
you will regret hearing this
for me today in four years
when you look back and
realize it now cost you
10 times as much to get to as many people
and it works half as well
because we got too used to ads
on those platforms.
I don't care what your opinions are,
I don't give a that you ready
you've ran on thousand dollars
and it didn't work, it
means you didn't know
what the fuck you were doing.
I don't get any of ROI from a
basketball, other people do.
I don't get any ROI out of
a piano, other people do.
The ROI out of Facebook and
Instagram ads is so gross,
so remarkable that you
have to go home and Google
how do I run Instagram ads, enter.
How do I get the most
effect for Facebook ads
for a real estate agent in
the Toronto region, enter.
You have to figure this out
because it is the best piece of advice
that I can give you on stage
and your romantic point of view
that Facebook's not cool anymore
or that you ran it already
or you don't get it or
you don't like the people
on their phones anymore,
your romantic points of view
or your headline reading points of view
is the vulnerability for your upside.
You have to be a practitioner.
The amount of people
here who have opinions
on influencer marketing, on Facebook ads,
on Snapchat filters,
opinions on all these things
without ever running a
fucking ad is egregious.
So the number one thing I
implore everybody here to do
is to go home and become a
practitioner at two things.
First, deploy self-awareness
and figure out
how you wanna speak to the world
whether as a person or a business,
is it written word, is
it audio or is it video?
Second, understand how to run ads
if you have a money to run
ads on Instagram and Facebook.
Period, end of story.
I literally can leave right now
and have given you more value
if you actually take it serious.
I know for a lot of you
have been following me
for a long time.
You've heard this before, many of times.
I just know that none of
you have gone all-in on it
enough for the value because
even I'm not going in
enough for the value
because the opportunity
is so ridiculous, right?
And so what happens,
how many people have
been doing their thing
and it's going well for over five years?
Raise your hand.
Raise them high, be proud.
Awesome.
You're the ones that I'm most scared of.
Because you get caught in your patterns
of what was successful for you.
This is what always happens, right?
YouTube works for Salon Guy.
You get caught, you get
used to it, it feels right,
you don't think about it,
or you get caught up in headlines.
You get lazy.
You know it's lazy when
Instagram creates stories
and you don't think you
need to do Snapchat anymore
'cause it's the same.
You're a fucking idiot.
You're an idiot 'cause
180 million people a day
use Snapchat and get
more consumption there
and Snapchat can make one
change that gets everybody back
but you don't wanna put the extra effort
for an extra minute or two
to get your content there.
It's so fascinating to me
how many people's actions
don't match their ambitions.
You know how many people roll up on me
whether virtually or in
real life and tell me
they're gonna buy the Rams or the Raptors
or something other than the
Jets 'cause we're cool like that
and then I go look at their Twitter handle
and they're watching entire seasons
of the fucking Crown on Netflix?
Our actions are not
matching our ambitions.
But let me say this
and this is just facts.
The fact that you're in this
hall this afternoon on this day
means that you see the world
in a very competitive advantage way.
You understand that something is happening
in a way that you understand
that I'm promising you 97,
98% of society doesn't.
That is your great strength,
that you understand this thing is real.
This is real.
You may not be fully advanced,
you may be in the nuances,
you might not be great at Instagram
but you're good at YouTube,
you've got a sense.
How many people here
have been following me
for longer than 18 months?
Raise your hand.
Thank you, and for 18 months or less?
Thank you.
The reason the hands are fairly even
is something changed 15, 16 months ago.
I took the advice that
I've been giving you
for the last eight to 10 minutes.
One of the things that I'm most proud of
is I never talk about shit I don't do.
When I tell you to bleed
out your fucking eyes,
I bled out of my eyes.
When I tell you to spend
more money and time
figuring out these platforms, I did it.
I don't guess.
You know why I don't have a lot to say
on crypto and Bitcoin?
'Cause I'm still tasting.
You know why I don't have my
official Vero point of view?
It's 'cause I'm tasting.
I don't like to talk about until I know
what the fuck I'm talking about.
- [Attendee] Yeah!
- The last 10 minutes.
(attendees applauding)
The last 10 minutes of
trying to get you there
and like pushing forcefully,
it's because that's what
happened to me 15 months ago.
Even for all my winning and I was followed
by a lot of people and a lot
of people knew who I was,
I wasn't all the way in.
Right, I was busy with Vayner,
I was doing other things
but Vayner got big enough
and my financial situation
got big enough that I was able to take it
from just me making my content
to three and a half years
later being 17 people
and a complete media team
that helps me put out
the obnoxious amount of content I did.
A lot of people have a
lot more money than me.
They're more than welcome to hire people
and go all in on this.
They choose to take those
dollars and buy things
or invested or do whatever
they want as they should.
I just want everybody
to understand one thing.
Attention is the asset.
Before you tell me what
you wanna accomplish
or what you want the customer to do,
whatever the customer is.
Get a vote, sign up for your platform,
whatever you want them to
do, you need their attention.
Attention in our society lives here.
And more importantly,
it's underpriced right now
in the ad products and the opportunity.
For the youngsters in
this room, it feels normal
so you can't realize how good it is.
For the people that are older,
they've seen this show before.
Television commercials in the 70s,
Google ads in the mid-2000s,
email marketing in '94, '95.
It just sometimes they don't understand
the pattern recognition.
I'm sitting here today
telling you one simple thing.
If you are not communicating to the world
on these platforms, you're invisible.
Fix it.
Thank you.
(attendees applauding and cheering)
- Give it up, guys.
Gary Vee, come on!
(attendees applauding and cheering)
Bring him on.
So guys, we don't have a lot of time
so we're gonna move quickly.
If you do have questions,
there are mics on this side
and that side.
Get lined up.
You know, I think this is
a good time for a quick
but cozy fireside chat.
What do you guys think?
- [Attendee] Yeah!
- Yeah?
Okay, so get your questions ready.
I can't emphasize enough,
the pace is gonna have to move quickly.
Oh and look at that.
Thank you.
- I will.
- So guys, a couple quick
rules about the Q and A.
(attendees cheering)
- [Gary] Let's do it.
- A couple quick ground rules.
We don't have a lot of
time so please no pitching.
If you're going up to pitch a
business, an idea, whatever,
please do not do it.
Keep in mind that there
are a lot of people here.
We wanna deliver value--
- Don't be a dick, let's go!
- Yeah, there we go.
And no selfies, guys, so.
Oh nice.
- [Gary] Oh, very nice.
- We actually have a legit fire.
- [Gary] It's cozy.
- So Gary.
(attendees cheering)
Nice.
- Is that person okay?
- Somebody is checking the
insurance policy as we speak.
- All right, let's do this.
- Okay, Gary so as we got
some people winding up there,
I got a couple things to kick it off here.
So after 10 plus years preaching
social media marketing,
what are people still
getting wrong in your opinion
as quickly as possible.
- I think how early it is.
I just think it's early.
Like I don't know what else to say.
Facebook is trading at $8 CPMs
on average, it should be 50
based on the attention.
Instagram Stories of trading
at five, four, three.
Grossly underpriced.
It's just early.
Like the land grab is real.
And so I just think
people are still debating
while it's actually happening.
- So at VaynerMedia,
do you see a disconnect
between what clients think they want
versus what they actually need.
- Of course, there's not a
single client at VaynerMedia
that does what I think they should.
There's not which is okay.
Listen, it's their money.
I'm in client services.
I wanna give them the right strategies
but they measure things
that I don't believe in
like reporting and rewards
and internal modeling mixes
that favor television.
Big companies are in trouble
right now in the world
because they're wrong.
They're wrong.
Like they think you watch commercials.
(attendees laughing)
So you you have a great speech there
about the value of Facebook
ads, Instagram ads.
I think there's a lot of people
especially in the audience that
may not have the investment
or prepared to kind of take
that leap onto the paid side
and are still looking for their angle
on kind of the organic.
And I think there's a lot of people
that are hung up on the old golden--
- That is beyond.
- Yeah, there's the
golden days of Facebook
organic reach and people got used to--
- It was fucking free.
- Yeah.
- You know, it was free.
Why are you mad that it reaches down?
It's free.
Your email reaches down too.
My email open rates in 1998,
in 1997 were 70, 80, 90%.
It's all cops and robbers, cat and mouse.
Like the only reason Facebook's doing that
is if you guys all saw
ads all day, you'd leave.
They're protecting their product.
Meanwhile, in parallel, the
ads are grossly underpriced
but you've made an emotional decision
that you like the better when
it was free and you value that
versus understanding that
if you spent a dollar,
you can make 10.
They're just not smart.
- Do you think there is anywhere right now
where content creators can gain an edge
prior to making that leap to paid?
Like for example when you are--
- I don't understand why that matters.
Like the pain is underpriced.
Now, it matters if you have no money.
So if you have no money, go to Craigslist,
go to the free section, right?
Pick up people's free shit.
Flip it on Facebook marketplace,
make yourself 500 dollars
by sweating a little bit and then run ads.
- Nice, guys, okay let's
take some questions.
(attendees applauding)
- Guys, you have to understand why.
Guys, I used to own the word
wine for five cents a click
out of Google.
I owned it.
It was five cents a click.
It's not five cents a click
anymore, you know why?
It's not 2001 anymore
and you guys know what the fuck Google is.
Like it's under priced ads right now.
Take advantage of it
because they won't be.
I don't know what else to tell you.
- Do you have a favorite
placement right now?
- You mean?
- In terms of like, you can
advertise on Instagram Stories,
you can do right side column, newsfeed.
Do you have a favorite placement?
- It's just feed 'cause
that's where people see stuff,
more importantly, I wanna
make sure you also understand
the difference between brand and sales.
A lot of you are struggling
because you just wanna sell
and all you're doing is
throwing the right hook
and maybe somebody doesn't
want your piece of shit,
$400 ebook.
(attendees laughing)
- Okay, let's get a
question from this side
of the room here.
- [Holly] Hey Gary, good afternoon.
- Good afternoon.
- [Holly] I'm Holly and
I'm one of these old women
in the room.
- [Gary] Okay.
- [Holly] Over 50.
- [Gary] Respect, you look great.
- [Holly] Thank you, and ring back to you.
- Good.
- [Holly] I'd love to launch my third app.
- Good for you.
- [Holly] And what would be
the biggest piece of advice?
'Cause I've been here, I've done it.
Had two apps, launched successfully.
They're doing well, good.
On to the third.
Told it will be healthcare.
- Okay.
- [Holly] What's the biggest
piece of advice you'd give?
- Well, what are you trying to accomplish?
Reinvent?
When you say we reinvent yourself,
try to get street cred and
notoriety and like leverage?
- [Holly] Yeah, I've
always played the field
of personal finance.
I'm considered one of Canada's leading
personal finance writers.
- So here's what I would say.
And I went through this
when I kind of transitioned
from wine to like more business content.
I didn't think a lot
about establishing myself.
I thought a lot about doing.
Investing in Facebook and
Twitter and Tumblr early on,
building VaynerMedia
from zero to 200 million.
That was my reinvented.
Don't worry about what
the fuck they think.
Go and execute a successful launch
and then you will be that.
It's the same thing with names.
Do you know how many people
here fucking spend weeks
coming up with their company name?
Like months, years.
- [Holly] Yeah, I spent a month.
- Yeah, that's a dumb
fucking move, here's why.
Names are made.
You think, look, Tim fucking
Horton's is a great name?
(attendees laughing)
Names are made.
Google's not a great name,
Snapchat's not a great name.
They become great names
because of the actions,
not because the name.
Gary fucking Vee with two silent Es,
are you fucking kidding me?
So make it the execution.
Don't worry about establishing yourself.
The results always fucking speak.
- [Holly] Thank you.
- Let's take one from
this side of the room.
(attendees applauding)
- [Sheldon] Hey, Gary, how you doing?
My name is Sheldon Bruce
from 2 Lined Music Hut
and I've been following
you about the past year.
- [Gary] Thank you, Sheldon.
- [Sheldon] And you
definitely changed my life.
- [Gary] That's great.
- [Sheldon] Last week, I
got my first $3,000 check
because of you.
- Thank you.
- [Sheldon] All right.
(attendees applauding)
What I wanna ask actually is
what is your take on hustle
versus investment.
- I believe in both.
I don't think they're conflicting, right?
I think hustle is investing
when you don't have money.
Like you have money or your time.
Like, and so like, I think
that both are essential.
I love investing financially,
I love investing in people,
I love investing in my audience
which is why I put out my
content for free, right?
I think investing is just
smart, it feels good.
And more importantly, shall
I started this talk with it
which is unless, like, look
I leave a lot of economics
on the table every year.
Now, if I die tomorrow,
from a business standpoint,
I left something on the table.
But for the most part, if I don't,
it will pay its dividends over the course
of a 50-year career.
Sheldon, you and every single person here
has never met anybody
who's been successful
without them working hard and hustling.
You may know somebody who
has a lot of money, right?
That they were given that money
but nobody here has achieved
without a lot of hard work.
Hard work is a prerequisite.
Like yes, the smarter and you work,
the bigger the upside, talent matters.
But to me, hustle is oxygen
because it's the number
one piece of advice
I can give to every single person here
and it doesn't matter
how good, smart or clever
or what they see is, it
is a variable of success.
So I'm a big believer both those.
- [Sheldon] Thank you.
- Thank you.
- That was a good one.
- [Sheldon] And I'm gonna
ask you another time
if you could be on my podcast, all right?
- 100%, done, I'll do it.
- [Sheldon] Thank you, Gary.
(attendees applauding)
- Okay, one from this side over here.
- [Attendee] Gary Vee, this is crazy.
Here with my birthday right now.
- Happy birthday bro.
- [Attendee] Thank you, man.
I didn't know I think I could be here so--
- 21st?
21st birthday?
- [Attendee] No, 23.
It's actually on Thursday.
- Damn it, I was close.
- [Attendee] Thank you to all the gents
who was out here too for
kinda, hey, Nick, Gabriela.
But I'm just I just wanted
to ask you a quick question.
So I just partnered up with my buddy.
We're doing a hockey apparel company
called Justition Hockey.
Were based out of Buffalo, New York.
- Okay.
- [Attendee] My question to you
is so we're big on for
online shopping right now.
- Of course.
- [Attendee] My question for
you is how can we increase
our conversion rates?
- Well, have better product.
- [Attendee] Okay.
- I mean a lot of people
don't think about that, right?
Because they only think
about conversion rate
has a lot to do with what's happening
once they're there, right?
So either your landing
page, your UI, your UX,
the copy, the images are
not grabbing people, right?
The other way you can do it
is by building brand, right?
So there's sales and brand.
But these get into the
like finite details.
I would scrutinize very heavily
the shopping cart experience
where the drop-off is.
This is all math.
Like where where the buttons are,
have they AB tested the color
of the ad to cart button,
a lot of technical stuff and then comma,
are you building brand?
Because people convert
better when they trust
or feel emotion.
So if they've heard of you
on Instagram or on a podcast
or things of that nature,
they'll feel more confident
once they get to that moment of truth.
So it's about black and
white technical nuances
of a website.
You know, mobile optimization,
things of that nature
and number two, really, are
you establishing a brand
that becomes trusted or loved?
- Gary, how do you balance
between not getting too stuck
in the minute details of
the green or red button,
like where's the balance between the data
and then playing off the emotion?
- For me, I don't get stuff
because if you become too math
our, you become commoditized.
There's a lot of people
here and a great at math,
they believe only in analytics and quant
and it gets them to a certain place
'cause it's an absolute strength
but it's also the same
reason they tap out.
'Cause the math always plays out.
If math was the variable, the
game would be over by now.
The art matters so incredible.
And so for me, I intuitively understand
the art quite well and I surround myself
with the biggest nerds
I can find on the math.
Those are two variables you have.
- [Attendee] Hey, just one more question.
- Go fast.
- [Attendee] Can I give
you my business card?
- Sure, but I will lose it.
I won't look it that way.
- [Attendee] What's that?
- I will definitely throw your
business card at the airport.
- [Attendee] Okay, that's fine.
- But you can tweet me and
be like I'm the 23 year old
birthday boy who's got the website
and that gives you a 13%
chance I'll look at it.
- [Attendee] Absolutely.
(attendees cheering and applauding)
I'll go with that.
Thank you, Gary.
- Okay, guys.
That's all we have time for today.
- Time out, time out.
Are you guys rushing
because of my heart out?
Because I'll sneak in two more.
- [Woman] Oh yeah.
- Okay, go ahead.
- You guys wanna do two more?
- Let's go.
- Okay, right side.
- [Attendee] Hi Gary.
That was great.
Thanks for the ticket.
- You're welcome.
- [Attendee] I came from London.
- Thank you.
- [Attendee] And you
may remember last year,
someone offered you to do a
backflip for an internship.
- Ah, what, a backflip?
- [Attendee] For an internship.
- Yes.
- And you said no.
- [Attendee] And I'm
gonna be the first to ask
this question in this form
and I'm also the first
to get a Gary Vee question it in London.
So my question is I'll
pay you $15 an hour,
that's the same amount
that you paying an intern.
- That's right.
- [Attendee] And I'll intern for you.
But two years ago, you
said I can be an intern
and you said yes.
For this year, I reverse it
and said I'll pay you to do this.
- So let's break this down.
Three years ago, I said,
yes, you could be an intern
but we didn't make it happen?
- [Attendee] You said email Atkinson.
- Cool, that's the most important part.
So now, where are you, in London?
- [Attendee] Yeah.
- Okay, so we have to fix that.
So email me at Gary of VaynerMedia.
Forward the original email, right?
And I'll make that happen and
you can keep your 15 bucks.
(attendees applauding)
- [Host] Okay, next question.
- [Attendee] Thank you for that.
One more question.
I made a documentary called Gary Vee,
Building a Honey Empire
and the premiere is on the 8th of March
in VaynerMedia, London.
Would you be interested in
a 10-minute Q and A session
down there whilst you're there?
- First, I'm trying to debate how hard
I should sue your fucking face.
Send me the details about it.
Let me take a look at it.
- [Attendee] Thank you.
- [Host] Okay, one more question guys.
This is the last question.
- [Attendee] I'll be really quick.
Gary, I heard you're a big fan of Altoon.
- Altoon.
- [Attendee] Altoon.
- My favorite all-time
your all-time Europe jam.
- [Attendee] Would you
accept this small gift
for being here today from me?
- You have some sort of Altoon thing?
- [Attendee] Maybe.
- Well, you better answer yes.
- [Attendee] Yes, yes.
- Okay, okay, come on up.
All right, next one, go fast.
- [Attendee] Gary, what's up, bro?
- Hey bro.
I'm gonna sneak a couple.
Go ahead.
- [Attendee] Just one.
Wholeheartedly thank you
and probably like 99.9%
of the people here, you've
done so much not only me
but for everybody in this
room and because of you
is why I'm here, man.
9 1/2 years ago, I discovered you.
We go back and it's because of you,
I'm almost at 500,000
subscribers on YouTube.
It's because of you is why in crushing it.
Thanks to you and just
thank you thank you bro.
Just what I'm gonna say.
- You're welcome.
(attendees applauding)
Thank you, bro.
Two quick things.
I'm gonna let you ask question.
- [Attendee] We can do it?
- Two minutes?
- [Attendee] Please, I'll be one.
- One minute, awesome.
Go ahead.
- Thanks, Gary.
- One minute.
- And real quick for all of you.
Sheldon, salon dude.
Guys, I'm just the
seed, it's cause of you.
I'm fucking pounding people 24/7, 365,
have hundreds of millions of people
at this point consume the content
and 99.9% of them aren't
doing dick about it.
It's 'cause of you and you, Sheldon,
that you're actually making it happen.
I'm just the fucking kernel.
- [Aaron] Gary, thanks
for taking this question.
My name is Aaron Spivak, I
got a quick question for you.
You're actually the reason
I dropped out of school
four years ago but.
And it's paid dividends.
- And real quick, are your parents here?
- [Aaron] They weren't happy at the time
but they're pretty happy
now so it's all good.
- Go fucking figure.
- [Aaron] Anyways, last four
years my brothers and I,
we built the franchise now seven locations
actually in the city.
We sell cold fresh juices
but what's been happening
recently is I've been
spending my time on nights
on some other things.
- Okay.
- [Aaron] And I wanna know how you feel
about diversifying
streams of income for me.
I mean other people are like
you should be putting 110%
into that one thing which I am but--
- I think that you're
entrepreneurial and your curious
and even if what you're doing
at night completely fails,
you needed to scratch that itch
and it's a hundred percent ROI positive.
- [Aaron] The this is it's
growing crazy right now.
- Go figure.
- [Aaron] There's only
so many hours in the day.
I mean I could sleep for
every night but at some point.
- Listen, I think it comes down
to are you willing to your brothers?
(attendees laughing and cheering)
See you!
- That's it, guys.
Give it up for Gary Vee!
(attendees applauding)
(upbeat music)